I I've made millions of pounds betting
that the average British family will
collapse into poverty desperate poverty
I'm talking about Charles dickins Oliver
Twist that is the future of this country
if we don't deal with growing inequality
that is what I see what are the biggest
problems that we face in this country
it's well I mean it's wealth inequality
it's wealth INE equality listen if you
allow wealth to flow at an unbelievably
rapid rate out of your middle class away
from ordinary Working Families away from
the government towards the super rich
then live standards will collapse
housing will become unaffordable
distribution matters if we're playing
chess and you take all of my pieces one
at a time I'm going to lose that chess
game that is what I see when I see the
economy we've seen government debt
explode we've seen living standards
collapse for all no working people at
the same time the biggest and fastest
ever increase in the wealth of
millionaires and
billionaires and nobody's connecting
these two things